i well welcome to everyone both familiar
faces and new people particularly we
haven't seen before it's very nice to
have you here and join us for this
conference throughout this conference
you're going to see a lot of technology
and ideas and details as well as zoomed
out views of what's happening but for
this talk I really wanted to zoom out
still further and I wanted to think
about some fairly basic concepts of
computation and how we're looking at how
to address those and see how we can
drive further into technical process so
that's why I've entitled a talk
injecting computation everywhere and the
idea is how can we drive in a sense
technical progress with ubiquitous
computation if we manage to have
computation doing all the things that it
can do how can we drive technical
progress as far as possible so that's
really the subject what I want to talk
about the next few minutes and I guess I
want to start with a question we all
take the idea of being able to compute
things as something that just has always
been there but actually in terms of
mechanized computations pretty recent
you know last 50 or 60 years is when
that's really kicked in the idea that
you could really compute something with
a machine of course the idea you can
compute something by hand goes back a
lot further than that but even that
isn't a natural idea to people if you
ask the average child whether they can
work something out like that they
wouldn't necessarily think so unless
they've been educated so one question is
it's a powerful idea it's so powerful we
take it for granted how much further can
it take us what can we do with
computation maybe that we haven't
immediately thought of doing where can
that go where can that theory of being
able to take rules and move them further
how far can that take us well I thought
it'd be useful to review a little bit
about what's worked well in the world so
far for computation and I think you know
I put down you probably have some other
categories one could put down
but let me go through these
traditionally computed computational
domains so things like physics you know
how did the planets go around the Sun
that's worked well for a long time as
something that computation could handle
things that we do on pencil and paper
worked well with computers you know
writing down basic sums doing some basic
algebra mostly these are things that are
very well structured models where it's
very clear what the abstraction of the
model is you can be very clear you can
write things down in a very constructed
way and then you can apply the rules of
hundreds of years potentially of working
out how you take that that question and
sense and turn it into an answer and
also simple to specify questions around
data things where you can ask a
relatively obvious question about data
and you can then get an answer of it so
those have worked well for a number of
years in with computation let's talk
about things that are still to develop i
would say sort of top of the list in
some sense is things with fuzzy
questioning things where we'd like to
get an answer we know there's an answer
in there there we know there are things
we could work out about it but we're not
quite sure kind of how to get to that
through the data or through the model
you know rapid deployment of new ideas
so oftentimes you know there's something
to be computed but it's kind of like how
do you rapidly get to the point where
you're really producing the answer that
how do you compute how do you get
everyone up to that speed as far as they
can go you know another thing again
which is troublesome remains troublesome
is how you communicate with computation
can you communicate active interactive
things or do you have to communicate
with traditional you know papers or
documents that are dead these are things
that are still not quite there in many
ways and sort of the utility of modern
data structures so traditionally most
things have been kind of you know
rectangle
it's a matrix it's a grid it's a tensor
but actually in the modern world that's
not really what you would like to do
you'd like to have data structures that
represent the data models that are set
up to be actually to do with the thing
you're modeling not in some very rigid
format because that helps you to move
those things much further and understand
them better so those are some of the few
of the things that I think are still too
developer and maybe you have suggestions
of other things as well that are kind of
on that list now it's also interesting
to review just a little bit that sort of
computational technical progress have
been an iterative have had an iterative
history so what happens is you know some
piece of science or engineering advances
that may actually cause computation to
advance for example if you make a
computer that works better because
you've discovered something new but then
the fact that you can compute more opens
up new areas of progress so the fact
that you can compute an awful lot means
we can now handle big data we couldn't
do that before because we couldn't do
mechanized computation so what you find
is that you're getting this sort of
ping-pong between computation and
technical progress sometimes it's it's
it's iterative it's sometimes also
recursive and that's a very powerful
sort of ping-pong and we need to go on
pushing that but it's sort of not
obvious always to see where that's next
going to go so I think my message is
we've done a lot with computation so far
but there's a heck of a long way to go
there are many many new channels of
computation that are going to open up
over the next years and decades which
will just make what's happening today
seem seem very basic and the way that
what's happening today makes what
happened 20 years ago or even 10 years
ago look pretty basic so I wanted to
take we had a special focus conference
on data science that's not the only area
where computation is applied but I think
often when people are working with
computation in the end you either end up
producing some data or you end up using
some data to make models either way or
both so I think it's a very important
area and one that clearly is developing
very far
so I wanted to talk through data science
expertise and kind of what we should
expect and what the issues are there to
give us a kind of a case study so let me
ask her a zoomed-out question again in
the world has more data led to better
decisions questionable right we have a
huge amount of data around the world now
and you'd think that that would mean all
the decisions were much much better it's
not clear expand out that way yet and
you know I would say one of the problems
right now is there's information
overload I mean some of us even remember
before the web right there was kind of
information under load then right you
couldn't get the basic data very much
and that was a problem everybody was
scrabbling around just trying to get
basic information now the problem is we
are all bombarded with huge amounts of
information we can find virtually
whatever we want but we all feel it's
kind of overloaded oh if only we could
figure out the stuff in this information
that we could really figure out then
somehow we'd be better and we're able to
make better decisions and by the way the
problem is getting a whole lot worse
right because we're clearly going to be
generating much more data than we are
now if you just look at your own
analytics you know when you're tracking
yourself as you run around and the
various everything you do in life is
somehow tracked in some way which you
may or may not like but the reality is
somehow that data is potentially being
collected and the question is can we use
it proactively and positively as opposed
to negatively and can we actually use it
and so the mountain of data is going to
get much much bigger so let me summarize
that today's data challenge I think in
order to get me in the end what you want
are these things is decisions right in
the end you want to know why how to
change something you're doing that's the
reason you're doing all of this work and
so in a sense today's data challenges i
would say these sort of three things can
you make available data accessible can
it actually be something that's
accessible not just out there various
governments particularly the UK in the
US have liked to throw data out and make
open data
the problem is nobody can really use it
so that means the data is available in
principle but except for a few
specialists it isn't really accessible
they're very different also taking
average and making it personalized so
this is a huge sort of change in the way
people in statistics in particular think
about things can you take us on average
situational on average you know our age
is acts but the real question is given
that your ages is why what is it that
the following character isn't given that
you have all these characteristics what
is true about the best guess of your
situation and you know making so I think
it's the summary of those is making
obscured obvious you want to take stuff
that seems obscured and make it kind of
very obvious so I think one solution to
help this is indeed highest level
computation for everyone and what that
means is many of you guys are specialist
computation people your people who are
very into doing technical analysis you
need to have stuff optimized for you but
you also need to be able to produce
stuff that's optimized for people who
are less technical than you so that
everyone across organizations and your
customers or clients or whoever it may
be or your students any of those people
can sort of operate at the highest level
of computation of that capable of doing
and that requires different different
ways to handle things so in a sense one
of the things I'm saying in data is that
we need to sort of empower the knowledge
community the consumer of knowledge to
generate their own knowledge see often
what happens at the moment is you if
you're consuming information you don't
drive yourself you're just given
something you look at it the question is
can you kind of drive can you be
interacting with what you've got and
that's kind of what I think an important
direction is for making making better
decisions happen and one of the things
that's notable is that expertise has
kind of got personal over the years so
if you look back into sort of history
you know there was a time when you got
somebody to type everything for you and
then we
processing came along and you did it
yourself there's a time when you know
you made you know graphics you had a big
graphics department making things etc
said the web did various things the web
app she was really two things i think
was personal fact-finding it was also
sort of distributing information
personally photography and now i think
you know for the last year or two we're
talking really about personal knowledge
generation and the question is how can
we empower that and in a sense is also
connected with personalizing data
science expertise so let's talk about
the barriers to this what's stopping us
make this take go further well I think
there are roughly three one is the
technology ecosystem will be talking
about that more later I think we can
help a lot with that another one is and
you know their various elements to that
interfaces deployment computational
power coherence I'll come on to those
computational data you know setting up
data so you can compute from it with a
computer seems seems obvious but it's
not what's being done in most places
most of the data pumped out by most
people is sort of for humans and also
something the subject of my talk later
today will be about how people can
improve so that they can operate in this
new climate of modern data science and
if I I'll change my I was going to talk
specifically about data science
education I think i'll talk about
instead is vision for global education
reform that that will from our embarked
on including this so how do we think
about how to address these problems take
you the technical ecosystem problem and
move forward well I always think a great
star for any of these problems is to
think about the interface what in the
end is what you'll go to produce and how
is the person on the end of it going to
use it what would you like their
interaction with it to be don't we start
with asking that question that always is
a help to knowing to working back and
figuring out whether you can build what
you want to build to do that so there
are many many interfaces and of course
one of the ones that we've been involved
in
what you might call linguistics where
you are trying to type something in and
get some sort of result so if for
example I some it's full screen again
sorry let's go so that's so let's do
something like cows in germany vs
population of UK or let's say london
actually and and let's see if we can get
a nalysis of that and there we go that's
actually it seems like london has fewer
cows in it other than than than germany
or people whatever actually and the
graph is sort of interesting there
anyway it seems like the penal i guess
so people have increased faster than
than cows there anyway um the now of
course as well as linguistic access
another interface is voice linguistic
access so if i if i ask my phone the
same question how many cows in germany
vs population of the UK except i change
the question ok and so we do that
courtesy of Apple's Siri you can
probably just see on my iphone screen it
did in fact work it out accepted the UK
so I guess that's a larger number and
you can you can see that we produce that
answer so that's a typical kind of
linguistic query where it's kind of like
you just want to talk to the thing you
just want to get a quick answers they're
kind of drive by querying of data and
obviously at something we've pioneered
but there are many other interfaces to
another thing we have done a lot of is
knowledge apps things where you want a
narrative and you want the user to be
able to drive so you want to give them
some sort of narrative to drive by and
but you want them to have some control
and a typical example of that might be a
sort of interactive report this is one
by Seth Chandler who is an economic
lawyer and this just looks like a normal
paper you know in the way that
actually no sorry this is not that this
is a different report this is a health
report she's a rather interesting one
this is a report of a Middle Eastern
country and this actually is anonymized
data of real results so you can test
yourself against the actual population
so here we are seeing you know if I'm a
if I've got these LDL and HDL levels and
I'm a smoker here's my actual risk of
different sorts of disease of heart
disease and this is actually modeled
directly against the population and you
know it's kind of nice i've got a paper
i've got a you know here here it is it
looks like just a dead document but it's
actually doing a highly complex analysis
here that's giving me real information
out so that's what i mean by the kind of
the knowledge consumer driving driving
the knowledge so one quick one question
you need to ask is what data are you
working from and one of the problems at
the moment is a lot of people are
working from you know that the focus is
can I make a piece of data that a human
could read you know an Excel spreadsheet
for example the trouble with that is
that data isn't usually set up very well
for what i would call citizen
computation it's not set up that well
for people to actually use a computer
like I have to work directly from and so
you've kind of got to work this from
both ends you got to get the data set
going so that it's usable immediately by
the computer and then you've got to have
the right computer interface for people
to use it and it's really cool when you
do that I mean this is a simple example
you may be aware of this in but if you
ask for example in the human genome
where does this sequence exist and
depending on how long or short I've made
it will see whether such a sequence does
exist oh my gosh I've picked one which
essentially just has two positions i
think on the genome and anyway so um you
know there we did we searched the human
genome it was already computable we
asked for those two that combination of
base pairs and there we got it that's
where the site is that's the sort of
power you have when you have computable
data and I must say actually I'm very
rare
pull that normally I do the length so
that it's like when I've done this so
it's either very long or I get nothing
but so there we go now we've been trying
to help with the process of actually
getting the data in the good shape to
start with as well as what we do when we
compute it so this year we launched data
drop and data drop is a is in a sense of
way to make an instant computable
database and whether it's from a device
or from your own kind of collected data
the idea is you can get things directly
from this and one of the things we are
just an example at she made it a rather
nice some a hackathon in Spain i believe
it was this is the so-called Boris bikes
in London and these are bikes you can
rent as in many cities to move yourself
around and this is so we did a pull from
their API every few minutes and we
dropped it into a data drop and we then
plotted around London where the bikes
are go during the day and it's kind of
interesting cuz I guess in the morning
everybody goes like to the city and so
all the bikes are full in the city and
empty outside then in the evening it all
goes the other way and then I think
there's some effect or the fact that
bikes tend to go downhill because people
prefer to cycle down hill than uphill so
the point is though this was a very
quick and easy simulation to do just a
few lines of code and you can get to the
sort of result in the middle of that is
the sort of data drop functionality and
i think that's that's kind of a nice
example of how easy you can make it when
you have when you have data working
correctly another thing we're trying to
set up is a data frame work so you can
set up your own data in the right form
to be computed immediate and that's the
Wolfram data framework and I think the
more that data can be set up that way to
start with that the better things can
work now one of the things that's
allowed us I mean one of the things
that's funny to me is that in a sense
people don't think of Wolfram us having
been central in data science for 25 plus
years but actually symbolic expressions
really and there are just a sort of very
flexible data structure and so actually
we r we find it very easy to represent
any kind of data we want to
and much more cleanly than as I said
earlier these rectangular systems so
it's kind of interesting to remember
that in a sense everything to us is data
and data is the same as functions as the
same as models because they're all
symbolic expressions now it's kind of
cool what you can do if you mash
everything together and one of the
things we learnt we used that we made a
few weeks ago actually is this image
identify site and the idea is you can
put an image in it and it will identify
the image and it's learnt stuff with
machine learning in order to produce
this and so there for example it's
figured out cheating it can pull stuff
from Wolfram Alpha and it's pretty nice
that you can wire all these pieces of
Technology together now I'm hoping to go
one step further here and see that's sir
let's try and do an actual live
computation here it has correctly
identified that I'm a person so that's a
good start now the mystery of the
pineapple yes sir we will we will test
the pineapple oh my god range hood
that's probably what's behind here
joinery well that's not bad um let's say
I have not tested a pineapple lampshade
edible fruit well that's that's not too
bad pineapple there we go we got it oh
maybe I should zoom out a little bit so
you get some that's it did pretty well
on fine yeah okay well no I think I
think it'll get horribly well let's try
it whether it picks up person and
pineapple or just edible I'm all edible
so and I you can have some fun with this
I mean what's cool is that one can
really let me see if I can scalpel ball
cutting implement rugby ball oh I see
you I guess it did look and so I guess
you can get disc it's it's coming but
it's so kind of confusing diskin circle
anyway you can play this for hours
frisbee I think frisbees probably the
best anyway it's pretty cool that all of
these things can be joined up and it's
uh it's exciting that we've been able to
manage to make such a thing rather
easily and produce you know the mixture
of the language and the data science and
the recognition etc etc has managed to
produce that so let me summarize about
data science I think you know lessons
about computation from data science
there's a long way to go we're only
scratching the surface and we've gone
decently far but we've got a lot further
to go there's huge power from a sort of
single unified environment and in a
sense having everyone be able to access
it like I could hold a pineapple up to
my camera is an important part of being
able to drive empowerment because you
need lots of people to be able to
interact with the data in this case to
be able to make that to be able to make
that work so what are the steps that we
see to inject in computation everywhere
for everyone what are the things we
think we need to do in order to achieve
that well let's start with what we've
got the thing that we've got that really
really helps this is one unifying system
of representing everything you know
that's only really really coming to life
now 25 years plus out from when we
started and you know as you know many of
you you know if i write maths you can
represent it in a functional symbolic
way if i write graphics you can
represent in the functional symbolic way
they all look the same under the surface
and the fact that these are all
represented the same way gives
tremendous power to what we can do and
that in a sense you know now more
recently data sets of joined as a new as
a new element of the of the of the set
up but these things all interact in
unexpected ways your images interact
with data interact with
symantec recognition interact with all
of these other things and the ability to
be able to do that is you're massively
multiplies the power of each thing so
another key technology that we are
really driving forward on very
successfully now is the hybridized cloud
model I want to talk about what people
talk about as cloud obviously in the
world people talk about the cloud and
software companies in particular say
we've turned of our software into cloud
software then the question is what does
that actually mean I think what it often
means is you can store stuff in the
cloud or sometimes you can run something
in the cloud what we mean by cloud is
you know compute store share deploy
universal access any or all of those
things some of it local some of it in
the cloud whichever combination you want
so that's why we've named it hybridized
cloud because to me the real power here
is not by saying suddenly we could give
up everything that's local and put
everything in the cloud the real power
is to say you know there's combinations
of cloud and local that optimize what we
want to do and actually you want that
optimization you know to give you a
simple example if you want to pull a
slider you know unless you have a very
fast low latency network to go to some
cloud device it's not going to be as
smooth as it is computing locally on
your machine on the other hand you don't
want people to have to install stuff
locally on their machine in order to run
something with a slider so one of the
problems we've had with computable
documents as you may know is that you
know it's required a local installation
of a plug-in or similar for somebody be
able to run stuff the cloud stops that
being a problem because the computation
can sit remotely and you can simply have
a web browser anybody with a standard
web browser can run interactive
manipulates you know by having this but
having the it's set up on the cloud you
know will it be as smooth depends on
their blatant same bag width and so
forth but it will work in a very nice
way and
immediately enables you to deploy
interactive documents and applications
to people everywhere knowing that they
can definitely get to them so that to me
is a huge good example of where kind of
a hybridized model works really well now
the other thing to make clear is we are
also taking our cloud technology and
turning it into private clouds so the
idea is that although you can use our
services in order to run cloud cloud
computations or all of these other
things that I mentioned you will also be
able to get private a version of that to
install in your organization so
effectively you have a complete you're
completely own setup and again that's
extremely powerful in fact that's
particularly powerful because some of
the issues over latency and so forth if
you're locally with inside your own
network actually go away when you have
cloud technology locally and so
therefore you really can kind of have an
environment where people just using
browsers and things to go a very long
way so i think that opens up a huge and
I know we've had fantastic interest in
private clouds from around the place and
particularly in Germany where people are
correctly concerned with their security
and things and I think that's a very
interesting development now another key
technology that we have been talking
about recently a lot is Wolfram language
we launched this as a separate sort of
items so to speak our last year really
Wolfram language has been brewing for
much longer than that because it's been
inside Mathematica but what we've done
is turn this into its own standalone
type of language and it's worth
remembering just you know what it what
it offers you know it's literate so you
can immediately see what you've written
much more than most languages it's sort
of multifaceted but unified and it's
also you know it was in an era already
when it when it first started emerging
we're kind of like the human trumps the
computer it's like very early languages
you're so worried about the power of the
computer that you made the language very
close to what the computer understood
and the problem with that is it makes it
hard for the human but we're in a modern
world where frankly
for the most part computer power is kind
of more than we need in many cases and
so not always but in many cases and so
it's more important designer language
that works well for humans even if it's
a little bit more effort for the
computer and of course then you want to
optimize it anyway so that in fact the
computer runs fast and often after a
time you can optimize it sufficiently
that you can actually do really really
well in making it just as fast as it
would have been if it was sort of very
close to the computer so the principal
who has been that and of course the key
thing is that the language is very much
attached to computation and so the
computations kind of ready to use that
and that seems a crucial thing and I
know over the last year in particular
people have really been latching on to
the idea of the Wolfram language and
thinking about Wolfram language in
comparison to other programming
languages not just to other computation
software and so we've had a lot of
people talking about how to use it
instead of Python and instead of Java
and instead of other things of that sort
where they hadn't really thought of it
as a language before and I think the
power of that will grow more particular
as we have the cloud applications
growing more one of things you may have
seen in the last year is tweeter program
and this was a program to be able to
tweet and maybe use some of you have
done this um the idea is that we have
such a powerful language that in 140
characters you can actually tweet a
meaningful program and so as you see
there have been 12 and a half thousand
nearly tweets and these are all the
programs people have come up with that
work in 140 characters so I think that's
a kind of a nice demonstration that we
have a highly compact language from
which you can do a huge amount in a very
sort of short short run now on the
challenges we've had is that we have an
awful lot of emerging technologies many
of you will be familiar in particular
being keen users for a long time of
Mathematica and the core technology
there underlies all of these other
things but actually we have many of
these different pieces emerging for
different uses for different sets of
people with different functionality and
so we have all these products emerging
up
and the project we've now embarking on
is how do we piece these together into
an ultimate computation system so we've
got the ultimate underlying piece we've
got the core unification of the language
and we've got many other pieces that are
very unified but we also want product
ization that is useful for many
different groups of people and so the
key sort of question is how do you piece
this together to get in a sense both
ubiquity and unification and one of the
things we've been thinking about for a
long long time I've shown this diagram
before is when you product ties things
do you make them discrete products or do
you make them sort of a continuous wave
of products across everything and we've
always believed that you should have
this sort of unification so you know you
can look at these different things there
were graph and network systems there are
high speed numeric system these are
peaks that in a sense we're above our
technological level but over time we try
and submerge these peaks and you know
the idea is that over time our overall
system actually can do better even at
the specialized ends of the spectrum but
even if it doesn't quite hit on some
polly particular area it's very you
don't have to build too much on top of
our system in order to be able to
supplant the the very specialized areas
and one of the things to notice if you
are in a specialized system kind of you
know on the top of a peak and you want
to do something just a little bit
different than what's on the peak it's a
long way to fall if you're in
traditional system as in you've got a
long way and it's also rather
uncomfortable sitting on a spike um so
it's very important I think to have this
sort of continuous functionality across
all of these areas of computation now
one of the problems with piecing these
things together is that it's harder for
us than anyone else why do I say that
because on the other hand the power we
can get out of that is also dramatically
more and it's a unique opportunity well
the reason I say that is because of this
what I call jus allottees and
hybridizations so one of our problems is
which is great problem to have but it
also makes my life harder
is that we don't have discrete sort of
differences between let's say
development and deployment if you look
out there most systems there are either
development systems or their deployment
systems they're not kind of halfway in
between they don't do both all in one
because for us deployment and
developments are kind of mixed you can
deploy an application to somebody and
they can change the code and they can
reuse it or they can adjust some facet
of it in a way that would never be
imaginable in other systems you know you
deploy a document to somebody and that's
the document there are people who have
the document there are people who have
this system that's there and you are the
developer and they are the deploy the
person to whom it's deployed so we have
these sort of what I call it's a bit
like wave particle duality right it's
like it's neither a wave you know nor is
it a particle or you can say that
there's a mathematical description that
represents both and there's just some
way you have to overlay on top of this
to think about what it is is a human
it's a bit like that with all of these
and you know symbolics numerics they're
not distinct for us there's kind of mesh
together we have symbolic representation
of numerics we have arbitrary precision
numerics you know these things are not
distinct they're not discrete
computation and coding traditionally you
have computation systems and you have
languages and they're kind of separate
they're not for us they're all together
the cloud and local I just talked about
how that's hybridized in our model of it
and data and expressions so the way you
have to think about we have is we have
this huge kind of space this continuous
space in all of these dimensions and the
question is how to piece that together
optimally with the core basis that we
have so let's also talk about sort of
facets of ubiquity how do we dry
computation to every where it can go
well we need to automate the insides and
we've done that rather effectively in
many cases although not all you need to
get it running everywhere so everyone
can use it on any device I think the
cloud helps a great deal with that and
you need to have coverage across all the
areas that you want to cover you know do
we cover what we need in machine
learning do
cover what we need in statistics do we
cover what we need in interface building
all of these sorts of areas are
important in terms of coverage in order
to achieve that and also how is it
productized do people understand what
they can get when they do stuff with us
so the big question I've been working on
is how do we marry ubiquity and
unification that's a big ask and I think
I won't go into too much detail here but
one of the things you'll be seeing
emerging is we're trying to build a
superstructure of what I call workflows
workspaces platforms and components so
the idea is that you either as a sort of
end user of something we've built or
indeed for making something for your
yourself or your clients or your
organization will be able to construct
any sort of any take on any of these
elements any of these dualities in the
easiest possible way I think the way to
think about that is to think first about
what workflow you really want to achieve
what do you want to start with what do
you want to end up with and how do you
get between those two using the whole
some of the technology now one elements
of that in a sense is how you present it
and what the workspace is and so in a
sense being able to construct
nice-looking workspaces is an important
element of that we've already started
releasing some platforms and starting on
like finance platform for example and
data science platform is is coming and
the point of those platforms in a sense
is to collect together work flows into
manageable chunks that people can
understand if that's all they want at
that at that stage in a sense and then
the components are in a sense of the
underlying pieces of chunks of
technology that really service that so
in a sense those are the elements that
we are piecing together into a sort of
superstructure and I think you'll be
very exciting us as this emerges so one
of the things we're making sure as a
company and we haven't always done these
things particularly well there's this
expression in English eat your own dog
food it's not as bad as it sounds it's a
software Express
which means if you build stuff you
should use it yourself and we've done
this very successfully for our own
computation one thing we're driving out
internally to do much harder to use all
of our development technology to develop
everything we need to develop as much as
possible whether it's our own ERP system
or whether it's are you know searches in
email systems or whatever we use our own
technology as much as possible because
most of these rely on computation and as
much as possible we think we should use
our own technology because then we iron
out all that work flow issues that we
are talking about so we are getting
better its so called eating our own dog
food product izing our ecosystem is as I
talked about the other thing is we want
to demonstrate the unexpected one of the
problems with our technology that these
dualities I talked about is it's hard
for people who are not the sorts of
people you are many times coming and
visiting Ursa so it's hard to explain to
them what is it that we can so cleanly
do for you and so one of the things and
I'd love to have examples from you all
as you as you think of them is what I
call sort of pivotal examples unexpected
examples where people think my goodness
I didn't know that computation could do
that or I didn't know the wolf from
ecosystem could produce that it just
seems like things that are wired
together that you wouldn't expect that
seems surprising and something I haven't
talked about much here but is absolutely
central is being the ultimate
development platform you know many of
you develop things for other people or
for your own organizations or for
yourself and it's crucial that those
things can be fitted together well and
that you can produce any of those things
that you want as quickly as possible and
another thing we're pushing on hard is
to be the center of what I call
computation led data science data
science as I mentioned has a long way to
go and I think we are emerging as in a
sense the people who do innovative stuff
in data science with computation and
that's a very powerful field whether in
health or finance or many many other
areas so to summarize we are in a sense
computation meets knowledge and I guess
our strategy is to build the ultimate
computation ecosystem
with you and involving you and I look
forward to hearing all the things in the
next couple of days that we can talk
about around that thank you very much